happening now a big step towards
planning for the Super Bowl which comes
here to Las Vegas in 2024 an event is
over at Allegiant Stadium happening
right now they've introduced members of
the host committee for Super Bowl 58.
Sports director Chris Matthews is there
live with the latest this is a big deal
Chris good afternoon
good afternoon John I'll tell you what
this is the first of many many many
press conferences prior to February 11
2024 when the Super Bowl will kick off
right here in Las Vegas now they're
promising it will be the biggest and
best Super Bowl that's ever been done
ever been established in the NFL so it's
pretty exciting times there and today
kind of kicked off the whole business
side and who's going to be the partners
the main Partners but there'll be a lot
more to talk about and joining us now is
the CEO and president of the Las Vegas
Super Bowl host committee Mr Joffrey
here and let me ask you how exciting is
this because now Sam it kind of we get
going now makes it real it makes it real
we've gone on record now this is kind of
our our coming out party for the host
committee as we officially announced not
just our executive committee members but
a lot of the Community Partners and
supporters that we have along the way
that have already come to the table uh
as we haven't even gotten into Phoenix
Super Bowl yet that's what I was going
to ask you Sam after Phoenix that's kind
of when we'll start seeing things
happening in Vegas right volunteers and
internships and different business
partners sure you know there are a lot
of things that happen to between now and
Phoenix for the NFL themselves they've
got championship games to produce and
they've got a Super Bowl to put on in
Vegas I mean in Phoenix but for Vegas
we're still meeting with them right now
and starting to lay the groundwork but
the majority of what you're going to see
is going to come to come in February of
2023 as soon as uh all eyes become in
Vegas at that point let me ask you now
you've worked with other Super Bowl
committees and been in charge of those
other Super Bowl committees is it fair
to say this one will be the biggest and
best and most exciting oh it's more than
fair to say that I think I like to say
that I think that when Vegas and the
Super Bowl finally come together it's
going to be like the Marvel and DC
Universe is collashing for the first
time it's going to be epic and over the
top all right Sam thank you very much
for joining us thank you for having us
there he is we'll hear much much more of
the next year and a half from Sam as
they get ready for Super Bowl
uh 58. 58 right here in Las Vegas yeah
58 right here in Las Vegas February 11
2024. reporting live from inside
Allegiance Stadium Chris Matthews eight
Sports now